I WILL SEE YOU HERE BACK
TOMORROW NIGHT AT 7:00.
TUCKER WAS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: AMERICA WENT INSANE
OVER THE WEEKEND AND IT’S BARELY
AN OVERSTATEMENT.
PEOPLE IN THEIR 80s WHO HAVE
LIVED IN THE U.S. ALL THEIR
LIVES SAID THEY’VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
THIS WAS WITHOUT PRECEDENT IN
THE MODERN ERA.
A SMALL GROUP OF HIGHLY
AGGRESSIVE EMOTIONALLY CHARGED
ACTIVISTS TOOK OVER OUR CULTURE
FORCING THE ENTIRE COUNTRY TO
OBEY THEIR WILL.
ALL HAPPENED SO FAST AND WITH
SUCH FEROCITY THAT NO ONE
RESISTED IT.
PEOPLE SEEM BEWILDERED, EVEN
STUNNED BY WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
STATEMENTS OF FACT AND OPINION
THAT WERE WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF
REASONABLE CONVERSATION SUDDENLY
A WEEK LATER WERE ENOUGH TO GET
YOU FIRED FROM YOUR JOB AND A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WERE FIRED.
AN AWFUL LOT HAPPEN THIS
WEEKEND.
FOR THE NEXT HOUR, WE WANT TO
ASSESS THE AFTERMATH OF IT ALL
TO SUGGEST WHAT IT MAY MEAN AND
WHERE THIS COUNTRY IS LIKELY TO
GO FROM HERE, BUT FIRST, WE WANT
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN TONIGHT IN
MINNEAPOLIS WHERE THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER RIOTS FIRST BEGAN
ALMOST TWO WEEKS AGO.
IS THE VIOLENCE THERE RAGED,
SOME DEMOCRATIC LEADERS CAME TO
A CONCLUSION THAT DIDN’T ON THE
SURFACE MAKE INTUITIVE SENSE.
WHAT THEIR CITY REALLY NEEDS,
THEY DECIDED, IS LESS
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN FACT, NO LAW ENFORCEMENT, SO
THEY BEGAN TO DEMAND THAT
MINNEAPOLIS DEFUND THE POLICE.
THE FIRST THING YOU NOTICE ABOUT
THIS IDEAS HOW UNPOPULAR
UNPOPULAR WITH THE PUBLIC IT IS.
ALMOST NOBODY IN THE COUNTRY
SUPPORTS IT.
BUT THE ACTIVISTS UNDETERRED
KEPT PUSHING THE IDEA AND WITHIN
DAYS PRESSURE MOUNTS ON THE
MAYOR OF MINNEAPOLIS JACOB FREY
TO GET RID OF HIS CITY’S POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THIS WAS A PROBLEM.
HE HAS GREATER POLITICAL
ASPIRATIONS AND THIS WOULD BE
THE LAST CONVERSATION YOU WANTED
TO HAVE.
SO HE DID HIS BEST TO CHANGE THE
SUBJECT WITH A MIX OF MANIC
ENTHUSIASM AND FEIGNED EMPATHY.
WELL PRACTICED IN THOSE AREAS.
HERE HE IS A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
WITH HIS PREFERRED BRAND OF
COMMUNITY OUTREACH.
♪ ♪
DIDN’T WORK.
THEN OR NOW.
ACTIVISTS WHO WANTED ACTUAL
ANSWERS, SO HE TRIED STEP TWO IN
THE PROCESS, GROVELING.
>> I’VE BEEN COMING TO GRIPS
WITH MY OWN BROKENNESS IN THAT
SITUATION, MY OWN FAILURE, MY
OWN SHORTCOMINGS.
>> Tucker: AGAIN, GOOD TRY.
AGAIN, NO DICE.
BLACK LIVES MATTER TO THEIR
CREDIT WANTED A REAL ANSWER TO
THEIR QUESTION.
IT WAS THEN THAT JACOB FREY MADE
A FATAL MISTAKE.
HE PUT HIMSELF IN A POSITION
WHERE HE COULD BE ASKED THAT
QUESTION DIRECTLY.
HERE’S WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
>> YES OR NO, WILL YOU COMMIT TO
DEFUNDING MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
WE DON’T WANT NO MORE POLICE.
STATEMENT I DO NOT SUPPORT THE
FULL ABOLITION.
>> YOU’RE WASTING OUR TIME.
>> GO HOME, JACOB, GO HOME.
GO HOME, JACOB, GO HOME.
>> Tucker: WHAT A REMARKABLE
PIECE OF TAPE THAT IS.
AS A BIG CITY MAYOR IN THIS
COUNTRY EVER BEEN MORE
THOROUGHLY HUMILIATED?
THE CORRECT ANSWER TO THAT
NEEDLESS TO SAY IS UP YOURS,
LADY.
I’M NOT GOING ANYWHERE, I RUN
THE CITY.
YOU DOUBT THE ENTIRE CROWD
WOULD’VE CHEERED JACOB FREY IF
HE’D SAID THAT?
PEOPLE ALWAYS ADMIRE RESOLVE
EVEN WHEN THEY DISAGREE WITH THE
POINT OF VIEW, BUT THAT’S NOT
WHAT JACOB FREY DID.
HE SLUNK AWAY LIKE A CHILD
CAUGHT DOING SOMETHING FILTHY.
THE MOST TELLING MOMENT CAME
JUST BEFORE THAT WHEN THE WOMAN
AND SUNGLASSES THREATENED TO
DEFEAT THE MAYOR IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
IT TELLS YOU THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER IS IN FACT A POLITICAL
PARTY.
MAYBE THE STRONGEST POLITICAL
PARTY OF THE UNITED STATES AS OF
TONIGHT.
ITS MEMBERS BELIEVE THEY CAN
RESHAPE THIS COUNTRY AND SO FAR,
THEY ARE PROVING TO BE RIGHT.
HE COULD ALWAYS TELL WHICH
POLITICAL MOVEMENTS ARE HEADED
UP BY HOW STRAIGHTFORWARD THEIR
MEMBERS AND SYMPATHIZERS ARE
ABOUT WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
STRONG PEOPLE SAY WHAT THEY
THINK OUT LOUD.
THEY ARE NOT EMBARRASSED OF
THEIR BELIEFS.
THEY THINK THEY ARE WINNING.
WITH THAT IN MIND, WATCH THIS
CLIP THIS MORNING.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
MINNEAPOLIS CITY COUNCIL LISA
BENDER.
SHE EXCLAIMS THAT THE DESIRE FOR
SAFETY, THE DESIRE NOT TO HAVE
YOUR HOME AND IS AIDED BY
VIOLENT CRIMINALS IS IN FACT A
SIGN OF RACISM.
>> DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THE
WORD DISMANTLE FOR POLICE FREE
ALSO MAKE SOME PEOPLE NERVOUS
FOR INSTANCE, WHAT IF IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, MY HOME IS
BROKEN INTO, WHO WOULD BUY CALL?
>> I HEAR THAT LOUD AND CLEAR
FROM A LOT OF MY NEIGHBORS, AND
I KNOW IT COMES FROM A PLACE OF
PRIVILEGE BECAUSE FOR THOSE OF
US FOR WHOM THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING, I THINK WE NEED TO STEP
BACK AND IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD
FEEL LIKE TO ALREADY LIVE IN
THAT REALITY WE ARE CALLING THE
POLICE MAY MEAN MORE HARM IS
DONE.
>> Tucker: HELLO, POLICE,
ARMED MEN ARE BREAKING INTO MY
HOME, HELP.
TO SHUT UP, RACIST, CLICK.
THAT’S THE WORLD LISA BENDER IS
CALLING FOR.
HOW MANY PEOPLE AGREE WITH LISA
BENDER?
THAT SOUNDS REASONABLE, CALLING
THE POLICE DEFINITELY QUALIFIES
AS RACISM.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE EVEN AMONG
CNN’S AUDIENCE THAT VERY MANY
PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT WHEN IT IS
SO OBVIOUSLY NUTS FOR IT ON THE
OTHER HAND, IT DOESN’T REALLY
MATTER AT THIS POINT WHAT THE
PUBLIC THINKS ABOUT ANYTHING.
IN THE CASE OF THIS IDEA, MANY
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE ALREADY
SOLD ON IT.
HE WAS FORMER CONGRESSMAN
KEITH ELLISON OVER THE WEEKEND.
KEEP IN MIND AS YOU WATCH HIM
SPEAK THAT HE IS NOW THE CHIEF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN
MINNESOTA.
HE’S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SAYING IT’S WRONG FOR POLICE TO
BRING GUNS TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CALLS, SERIOUSLY.
>> WE SEND OUT PEOPLE WITH GUNS
AND THEY ARE TO USE DEADLY FORCE
NO MATTER WHAT THE PROBLEM MAY
BE.
THE PROBLEM IS SEXUAL ASSAULT,
WE BRING SOMEBODY WITH A GUN.
THE PROBLEM IS SOMEBODY IN THEM
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS, WE SEND
SOMEBODY WITH A GUN.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE THINKING, THAT IS
KEITH ELLISON, KIND OF AN UNFAIR
EXAMPLE, HE HAS LONG BEEN A
CRAZY PERSON WHO WAS ONCE
ATTACHED TO THE NATION OF ISLAM
AND BACK THEN CALLED HIMSELF
KEITH HAKIM.
MORE RECENTLY, HE ENDORSED
ANTIFA AND THAT IS ALL TRUE BUT
UNLIKE OTHER RACE BAITING
EXTREMIST, HE MAY HAVE A
PROMISING POLITICAL FEATURE,
VERY INTERESTING TO IMAGINE IT.
HE COULD BE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES.
AT THE VERY LEAST, HE WOULD BE
FIRST IN LINE TO BECOME THE U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE STATE OF
MINNESOTA, THE TOP FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR THERE.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN THEN?
WE MAY LIVE TO FIND OUT.
ALL OF THIS PROBABLY STRIKES YOU
AS VIOLET DIED CRAZINESS,
ELIMINATE THE POLICE, REALLY?
BUT THINGS CHANGE FACT.
LOOK AT HOW QUICKLY THEY CHANGED
JUST OVER THE WEEKEND.
THE SKILLED TRENDS BOTTOM IF
THERE EVER WAS ONE IS ALREADY
ACTING AS IF TO DEFUND THE
POLICE, A PROPOSAL THAT NO SANE
PERSON EVEN MENTIONED IN PUBLIC
JUST LAST MONTH IS NOW THE
DEFINING CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF
OUR TIME.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A BIGOTED
DINOSAUR, A BAD PERSON TO OPPOSE
IT.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS.
THIS RIGHT NOW IS ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS.
YOU ARE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL OR
ANY REASON ON THIS CALL.
I AM ACTING YOU TO ASK YOURSELF
WHAT ARE YOU WILLING TO
SACRIFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT
OVERFUNDED POLICE DEPARTMENT’S
ARE DEFUNDED.
>> Tucker: SO THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU JUST SAW.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ ISN’T
JUST A MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
SHE’S MAYBE THE MOST FAMOUS
MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND IS ALSO A
SURROGATE FOR JOE BIDEN SO A LOT
IS ON THE LINE HERE.
SHE DIDN’T SAY THAT
ACCIDENTALLY, SHE HAD A REASON
FOR SAYING IT.
WHY DID SHE SAY THAT?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
AS USUAL, THE TRUTH BEARS NO
RESEMBLANCE WHATSOEVER TO WHAT
THEY ARE TELLING YOU.
THINK ABOUT IT, DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS CONTROLLED THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN VIRTUALLY
EVERY BIG CITY IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOW THEY ARE TELLING YOU THEY
WANT TO GET RID OF THOSE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
THEY DID, THAT WOULD MEAN LESS
POWER FOR THEMSELVES SO RIGHT
AWAY, YOU KNOW THERE’S LYING
GOING ON.
DEMOCRATS DO NOT RELINQUISH
POWER VOLUNTARILY.
DEMOCRATS NEVER DO, SELECT THE
FIRST THING TO KNOW, SOMETHING
OBVIOUSLY IS GOING ON HERE
BENEATH THE SURFACE.
THIS HAS TO BE AN ATTEMPT TO
INCREASE THE POWER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE EVERY
POLICY THEY PUSH IS.
ALWAYS.
AND IN FACT, THAT’S EXACTLY
WHAT’S HAPPENING.
YOU WILL HEAR THEM ADMIT THAT.
INSTEAD, THEY WANT TO REPLACE
THE POLICE.
IN TAKE THE PEOPLE WHO CURRENTLY
HAVE BADGES, MANY OF WHOM VOTED
FOR DONALD TRUMP AND SWAP THEM
OUT FOR NEW PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO
HATE DONALD TRUMP AND HATE THE
PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING, AND IT MAKES SENSE
GOOD LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ONE OF
THE VERY FEW INSTITUTIONS
REMAINING IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
THE LEFT DOES NOT YET
CONTROLLED.
DEMOCRATS HATE THE POLICE
BECAUSE THEY DON’T CONTROL THE
POLICE.
VERY SIMPLE.
REMEMBER 35 YEARS AGO WHEN
DEMOCRATS WERE CONSTANTLY
ATTACKING THE U.S. MILITARY?
YOU DON’T HEAR THAT ANYMORE.
WHY IS THAT?
IT’S VERY SIMPLE.
THE LEFT TOOK OVER THE PENTAGON.
NO REASON TO ATTACK PEOPLE YOU
CONTROL, WHICH THEY DO.
AND THEY PLAN TO DO THE SAME
THING TO YOUR LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE PROPOSING
ISN’T SOME FORM OF RADICAL
LIBERTARIANISM, NO.
IS THE OPPOSITE OF THAT.
WHAT THEY ARE PROPOSING IS A
POWER GRAB.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE AS A MOVE
TOWARD AUTHORITARIAN SOCIAL
CONTROL CLOAKED IN THE LANGUAGE
OF IDENTITY POLITICS.
ALREADY IN THE MIDDLE OF A TOTAL
BREAKDOWN OF LAW AND ORDER AS WE
WATCH OUR CITIES BURN, YOU ARE
SEEING NEW MOVES TO PREVENT YOU
FROM DEFENDING YOURSELF AND YOUR
FAMILY IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
JUST LAST TUESDAY, WAS RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS IN GEORGIA POSTED
THIS AD ON FACEBOOK AND WITHIN
TWO DAYS, FACEBOOK PULLED IT
DOWN.
>> I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR ANTIFA
TERRORISTS, STAY OUT OF
NORTHWEST GEORGIA.
YOU WEREN’T BURN OUR CHURCHES,
LOOT OUR BUSINESSES, OR DESTROY
OUR HOMES.
>> Tucker: SO FACEBOOK HAS A
POLICY AGAINST VIOLENCE, NOT THE
VIOLENCE AND ENGULFING OUR
CITIES, BUT THE VIOLENCE OF YOU
DEFENDING YOUR FAMILY.
THEY CREATE THE CHAOS, YOU ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO DEFEND YOURSELF.
YOU ARE IN OTHER WORDS WHOLLY
DEPENDENT UPON THEM.
IN THE FUTURE, THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO WILL HAVE GUNS ARE PEOPLE ON
THEIR TEAM, AND THAT’S EXACTLY
WHAT DO YOU FUND THE POLICE
REALLY MEANS.
MEANS A WOKE MILITIA POLICING
OUR CITIES AND ENFORCING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ORTHODOX.
IMAGINE IF THE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION DEPARTMENT HAVE THE
POWER TO ARREST YOU.
IMAGINE IF THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER RIOTERS HAD WEAPONS AND
IMMUNITY FROM PROSECUTION.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
PARTISAN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT’S HARDLY WITHOUT PRECEDENT.
IN FACT, IT’S A RULE.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO BRING IT
HERE.
WHAT IS AGAIN A STRIKING IS HOW
FEW AMERICAN VOTERS SUPPORT
THIS, VERY FEW.
PULLING FROM JUST A WEEK AGO
SHOWED THAT ONLY 16% OF
AMERICANS FAVORED CUTTING
FUNDING FOR POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
THERE WAS ALMOST NO PARTY DIVIDE
ON THAT QUESTION SURPRISINGLY.
THE NUMBERS WERE VIRTUALLY THE
SAME FOR REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
THE DIVIDE WAS ECONOMIC.
YOU MAKE A MORE THAN $100,000 A
YEAR, YOU ARE MORE THAN TWICE AS
LIKELY TO THINK CUTTING THE
POLICE WAS A GOOD IDEA, AND
THERE’S NO MYSTERY THERE, OF
COURSE, THEY CAN AFFORD THEIR
OWN SECURITY.
JEFF BEZOS DOESN’T NEED THE
POLICE, HE’S GOT HIS OWN.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE REST OF
US, AND IT IS UNFORTUNATE,
JEFF BEZOS AND PEOPLE LIKE HIM
ARE THE ONLY ONES ALLOWED TO
TALK RIGHT NOW.
IT’S HARD TO OVERSTATE HOW
VICIOUS THE CRACKDOWN ON FREE
SPEECH AND FREE THOUGHT HAS BEEN
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
HERE’S THE NEW RULE, YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO QUESTION BLACK LIVES
MATTER IN ANY WAY.
FALSE.
THAT RULE HAS BEEN IN FORCE
WITHOUT MERCY EVERYWHERE AND NOT
JUST IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN VANCOUVER, A MEN’S BASKETBALL
COACH WAS FIRED FOR LIKING A
TWEET THAT QUESTION BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
MEANWHILE, A PLAY ON THE L.A.
GALAXY WAS FIRED BECAUSE HIS
WIFE SAID SOMETHING CRITICAL
ONLINE.
NOT HIM BUT HE DIDN’T DO IT.
HIS WIFE.
DOESN’T MATTER.
THEY CAN TO THE PLAYER ANYWAY.
IMAGINE BEING A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT RIGHT NOW.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO REFUSE
TO SHOW AFFIRMATIVE SUPPORT ON
THEIR INSTAGRAM ACCOUNTS WERE
SHUNNED BY THEIR FRIENDS.
JOURNALISTS WHO ASKED TOO MANY
QUESTIONS WERE FIRED OR
SILENCED.
AGAIN, NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
YOU THINK PEOPLE IN MEDIA WOULD
RESENT THIS, PRESUMABLY SOME DO,
BUT ALMOST EVERYBODY STAYED
QUIET ABOUT IT.
SOME APPLAUD IT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RAN AN
OP-ED DEMANDING THAT PEOPLE
DISOWN THEIR OWN FAMILIES IF
THEIR FAMILIES FAILED TO SUPPORT
BLACK LIVES MATTER
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ENOUGH.
TELL YOUR RELATIVES, TELL YOUR
FRIENDS THAT "YOU WILL NOT BE
VISITING OR ANSWERING PHONE
CALLS UNTIL THEY TAKE
SIGNIFICANT ACTION AND
SUPPORTING BLACK LIVES THROUGH
PROTEST OR FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS.
GOT THAT?
SORRY I’M A MOM.
I KNOW YOU ARE OLD AND ALONE AND
MISS YOUR GRANDCHILDREN, BUT WE
ARE SHUNNING YOU UNTIL YOU SEND
MORE MONEY TO BLACK LIVES MATTER
MATTER.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS,
WE’VE NEVER LIVED IN AN
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS, BUT YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
MOST PEOPLE GET THE MESSAGE VERY
FAST.
AND THE WEAK ONES ARE QUICK TO
JOIN AND JUST LIKE THE GOOD
LITTLE RED GUARDS THEY’VE ALWAYS
BEEN UNDERNEATH IT ALL.
HERE IS MITT ROMNEY.
>> VIOLENCE AND BRUTALITY AND
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT BLACK LIVES MATTER.
>> Tucker: HE JUST WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT AMERICANS
UNDERSTAND THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
AS IF AMERICANS DIDN’T KNOW THAT
THAT.
BUT ACCUSING YOUR ENTIRE COUNTRY
OF RACISM TURNS OUT TO BE A
PRETTY SMALL PRICE FOR SOMEONE
LIKE MITT ROMNEY.
WHAT HE IS REALLY WORRIED ABOUT,
WHAT ALL THE FINANCE MOGULS
FINDING THIS MOVEMENT ARE
WORRIED ABOUT IS THAT SOMEONE
SOMEWHERE WILL ASK THE OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU MADE, HOW RICH
HAVE YOU BECOME BY SENDING JOBS
OVERSEAS, BY CHARGING OBSCENE
INTEREST RATES AND BY OTHERWISE
HARMING THE POOR AND BLACK
COMMUNITIES ECONOMICALLY?
ALL THE BASIC CRIMES ARE
ECONOMIC.
MITT ROMNEY DOESN’T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT AT ALL, SO HE
MARCHES.
AND BLACK LIVES MATTER COULDN’T
BE HAPPIER ABOUT IT.
THE COMPLICITY OF PEOPLE LIKE
MITT ROMNEY GIVES GROUPS LIKE
BLACK LIVES MATTER STRENGTHS.
A BLACK LIVES MATTER IS BECOMING
MORE POWERFUL BY THE HOUR AND
THEY KNOW IT.
WATCH THIS INTERVIEW FROM
SATURDAY IN WHICH A BLACK LIVES
MATTER ACTIVIST CHEERFULLY
ADMITS HE MAY SOON INCINERATE
PEOPLE WITH GASOLINE.
>> IT MEANS A LOT OF THINGS.
COULD MEAN FOR THE PEOPLE AND IT
COULD ALSO MEAN FIRE INTO
PROPERTY.
WE ARE HOPING THEY COME OUT AND
TALK TO US AND GIVE THE YOUTH
SOME DIRECTION BUT IF THEY
DON’T, THEN GASOLINE IS AWFULLY
CHEAP.
>> Tucker: THE AMAZING THING
IS NOT JUST THAT HE SAID THAT,
THOUGH THAT’S SHOCKING ENOUGH.
THE AMAZING THING IS THAT HE SET
IT ON TELEVISION LIVES.
HE WASN’T WORRIED ABOUT BEING
ARRESTED.
IN YOU WERE STILL NOT ALLOWED TO
ATTEND CHURCH SERVICES OR GO TO
BIG WEDDINGS.
TOO BAD YOU ARE NOT FRIENDS WITH
MURIEL BOWSER.
HE COULD DO ANYTHING.
HE HAS RENAMED A PARK BLACK
LIVES MATTER PLAZA AND NO ONE
CRITICIZED HER FOR IT.
PRACTICALLY SENT HER FLOWERS.
>> HAVING A MURAL OF BLACK LIVES
MATTER IN HUGE BLACK LETTERS
ACROSS THREE BLOCKS LEADING UP
TO THE WHITE HOUSE, AS I SAID DO
YOU WANT TO SUNDAY, BAD MOVE
THAT YOU MADE.
>> IT IS A REPRESENTATION OF AN
EXPRESSION OF OUR SAYING YOU
KNOW, BUT ALSO IDENTIFYING AND
CLAIMING A PART OF OUR CITY THAT
HAD BEEN TAKEN OVER BY FEDERAL
FORCES.
>> Tucker: WAS BLEEDING
GRATIFIED BY THE SUPPORT SHE
RECEIVED, SO SHE ALSO HAD BLACK
LIVES PATRICK WOW MATTER PAINTED
ON AN ENORMOUS YELLOW LETTERS.
A KIND OF A BOLD MOVE IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, MAKING A STREET
PARTISAN.
IMAGINE A BIG CITY MAYOR NAMING
A MAJOR THOROUGHFARE NRA AVENUE
OR PLANNED PARENTHOOD BOULEVARD.
IT’S IMPRESSIVE IN A WAY, BUT
BLACK LIVES MATTER WASN’T
SATISFIED BY IT, NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THE D.C. CHAPTER RELEASED A
STATEMENT ATTACKING MAYOR BOWSER
FOR NOT GIVING COMPLETE CONTROL
OF THE CITY’S POLICE DEPARTMENT.
"THIS IS TO APPEASE WHITE
LIBERALS WHILE IGNORING OUR
DEMANDS.
BLACK LIVES MATTER MEANS DEFUND
THE POLICE.
GOT THAT?
BLACK LIVES MATTER MEANS DEFUND
THE POLICE.
SO THAT’S WHAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER MEANS.
NO ONE REALLY EXPLAINS THAT.
NOW WE KNOW WITH INTEL AND PEPSI
AND AMAZON ARE SUPPORTING WHEN
THEY SEND MONEY.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
SUDDENLY IT FEELS LIKE ALL THE
ADULTS HAVE GONE TO SAINT
BARTH’S AND TURNED OFF THEIR
CELL PHONES.
WHO WAS RUNNING THIS COUNTRY?
WHO’S IN CHARGE?
ANYONE?
YET AMAZINGLY, SOME REPUBLICANS
IN WASHINGTON SEEM GIDDY AS THEY
WATCH THE COUNTRY GO INSANE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE GONE TOO FAR THIS
TIME, THEY WILL TELL YOU.
WE ARE GUARANTEED TO WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
PROBABLY GOTTEN TEXT TO OF THAT
AFFECT RECENTLY FROM FRIENDS.
SOUNDS GOOD, BUT THEY ARE WRONG.
THEY ARE TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
WRONG ON MANY LEVELS.
BUT ONE THING IF YOU CARE ABOUT
A COUNTRY, YOU’VE GOT TO TRY.
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO TRY
YOUR VERY BEST TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND IT NO MATTER WHO IS
HELPED IN NOVEMBER.
THAT’S WHAT PATRIOTISM IS.
NOT ABOUT YOU, IT’S ABOUT
AMERICA.
EVEN AS A MATTER OF PEER
POLITICS, THIS IS A MINDLESS
ANALYSIS, A STUPID CALCULATION.
BAD IDEAS ARE LIKE CANCER.
WHEN YOU IGNORE THEM AND PRETEND
THEY ARE NOT THERE, THEY SPREAD.
MOST PEOPLE AS WE NOTED
CURRENTLY OPPOSED DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
THAT IS WHERE THE POLLS STAND
RIGHT NOW.
BUT WILL THEY FEEL THAT WAY IN
THREE MONTHS?
HOW ABOUT IN THREE WEEKS?
IN AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS, YOU
DON’T KNOW.
THIS MOVE FAST.
COMMISSIONER ONCE OPPOSED
MOCKING AMERICANS LIKE ANNEALING
TO ATTACK THE COUNTRY IS RACIST,
NOW HAS ANNOUNCED HE IS WITH
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
>> WE ADMIT WE WERE WRONG FOR
NOT LISTENING TO NFL PLAYERS
EARLIER.
AND ENCOURAGE ALL TO SPEAK OUT
WILL BE PROTEST.
WE AT THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL
LEAGUE BELIEVE BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
I HAVE PERSONALLY PROTEST WITH
YOU.
>> Tucker: OF THIS IS SO GOOD
FOR REPUBLICANS, EXPLAIN THIS.
WHY DOES THE LATEST ROUND
INDICATES THAT JOE BIDEN’S LEAD
IN THIS RACE IS GROWING?
AND THAT’S NOT A SMALL THING IF
YOU PLAN TO LIVE HERE.
YOU DON’T WANT TO LIVE UNDER
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEITH ELLISON,
SO WHY IS IT HAPPENING?
MAYBE IT’S BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
IN WASHINGTON HAVE DECIDED TO
SIT THIS CRISIS OUT.
THEY HAVEN’T BOTHERED TO EXPLAIN
WHAT’S WRONG.
THEY HAVEN’T BOTHERED TO TELL US
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE
FLAWED ABOUT BLACK LIVES MATTER,
AND THEY DON’T PLAN TO.
THEY ARE TOO CYNICAL, TOO
FEARFUL.
THEY ARE GOING TO PEN LIKE IT’S
NOT HAPPENING, REPEAT
PLATITUDES, READ BUMPER STICKERS
ON THE AIR, NOD SOLEMNLY, AND DO
NOTHING TO PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
WHY WOULD VOTERS REWARD THAT?
DEMOCRATS BY CONTRAST WHO ARE
COMPLETELY WRONG AND ARE LEADING
US DOWN A PATH THAT WON’T END
WELL AREN’T SHAMED IN THE
SLIGHTEST OF WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
THEY BRAG ABOUT IT JUST LIKE
THEY KNEELED IN SUBMISSION.
>> WE ARE HERE TO HONOR GEORGE
FLOYD.
FOR THOSE WHO WISHED, WE WILL
NOW KNEEL FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE.
>> Tucker: NANCY PELOSI DOING
SOMETHING CRAZY AGAIN.
KEEP IN MIND, IT WASN’T JUST
NANCY PELOSI, NOT BY A LONG
SHOT.
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
KNEELED TOO.
SO DID A GROUP OF FBI AGENTS, SO
DID THE PRIME MINISTER OF CANADA
DONNA JUSTIN TRUDEAU WHO OTHER
DAY WAS WEARING BLACK FACE.
THE POLICE CHIEF OF WEBSTER
MASSACHUSETTS WENT EVEN FURTHER
THAN THAT.
HE LAID ON THE GROUND AND
COMPLETE SUBMISSION.
AND THEN THINGS BEGAN TO SPIN
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL NOT
JUST IN THIS COUNTRY, BUT
THROUGHOUT THE WEST AS THE CROWD
SWELLED AND THE DEMAND FOR TOTAL
IDEOLOGICAL CONFORMITY GREW
LOUDER, THIS LATEST CULTURAL
REVOLUTION BECAME A PARODY OF
ITSELF AS THEY ALWAYS DO.
IN LONDON, PROTESTERS VANDALIZED
THE STATUE OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN
BECAUSE WHAT IT ABRAHAM LINCOLN
EVER DO FOR BLACK PEOPLE?
A MOB DEFACED A MONUMENT TO THE
FIRST ALL-BLACK VOLUNTEER
REGIMEN IN THE CIVIL WAR BECAUSE
BLACK PEOPLE DYING TO END
SLAVERY SOUNDS LIKE WHITE
SUPREMACY TO US.
AROUND THE SAME TIME, A LAW
PROFESSOR FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO CALLED FOR AN ARMED COUP
TO OVERTHROW THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, BUT THAT
DIDN’T FELT GET A LOT OF PRESS
BECAUSE IT DIDN’T SEEM
PARTICULARLY NEWSWORTHY UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCE.
WAS THAT KIND OF WEEKEND.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
EVEN THE OUTLINES ARE BLURRY AT
THIS POINT, BUT WE KNOW THIS, NO
MATTER WHAT THEY TELL YOU, IT
HAS VERY LITTLE TO DO WITH BLACK
LIVES, IF ONLY IT DID.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS CARED ABOUT
SAVING THE LIVES OF BLACK
PEOPLE, AND THEY SHOULD, THEY
WOULDN’T IGNORE THE MURDER OF
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG BLACK MEN IN
THEIR CITIES EVERY YEAR.
THEY WOULDN’T PUT ABORTION
CLINICS IN BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY WOULD INSTEAD DO THEIR VERY
BEST TO IMPROVE THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND TO ENCOURAGE INTACT
FAMILIES WHICH WE KNOW BEYOND A
SHADOW OF A DOUBT IS CENTRAL TO
THE LIFE PROSPECTS OF CHILDREN.
THEY TRIED TO MAKE BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS AS SAFE AS THEIR
OWN NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY CLOSE THE PAYDAY LENDERS
THAT ADD SO MUCH MISERY TO
PEOPLE OF ALL COLORS.
BUT THEY DON’T EVEN CONSIDER
DOING ANY OF THIS, THEY DON’T
EVEN TRY.
INSTEAD, THE ENCOURAGE THEFT AND
MAYHEM AS IF THAT WILL HELP.
WILL NOT HELP.
THIS MAY BE A LOT OF THINGS,
THIS MOMENT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH, BUT IT IS DEFINITELY
NOT ABOUT BLACK LIVES AND
REMEMBER THAT WHEN THEY COME FOR
YOU AND AT THIS RATE, THEY WILL.
ANYONE WHO HAS EVER BEEN
SUBJECTED TO THAN BOB KNOWS THE
FEELING.
IT’S LIKE BEING A SWARMED BY
HORNETS.
AND THE TEMPTATION IS TO PANIC.
HAVE TO KEEP YOUR HEAD AND TELL
THE TRUTH.
YOU SHOW WEAKNESS OF ANY KIND,
THEY WILL CRUSH YOU.
ASK YOUR BREEZE.
BY SOME ACCOUNTS, BOARDROOM
BREEZES ON HIS FOURTH APOLOGY
FOR THE CRIME OF DEFENDING THE
AMERICAN FLAG.
HE DECIDED TO APOLOGIZE AND NOW
THEY ARE USING HIM AS A
PROPAGANDA WORKING HOSTAGE TAPE
AFTER HOSTAGE TAPE.
AT A MOMENT LIKE THIS, THERE IS
NO ADVANTAGE IN COWARDICE, IN
BEING MET ROMNEY.
YOU THINK YOU’RE SAVING YOURSELF
BUT YOU’RE JUST EMPOWERING THE
WORST PEOPLE MY PEOPLE WHO HATE
YOU.
BEFORE YOU KNOW IT, CONFESSING
TO CRIMES YOU DIDN’T COMMIT.
IN TELL THE TRUTH, AND THE TRUTH
IS THIS IS A GOOD COUNTRY, BEEN
BETTER THAN ANY OTHER.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO BE ASHAMED
OF.
IMMIGRANTS KNOW THAT BEST OF
ALL.
THAT’S WHY THEY COME HERE.
A MILLION NEW AMERICANS EVERY
YEAR.
THEY ARE NOT COMING BECAUSE
AMERICA IS A RACIST COUNTRY.
THEY ARE COMING BECAUSE IT’S
NOT.
THAT IS ALL TRUE.
AND THEY WERE CLEAR MOMENTS WE
KNOW IT’S TRUE, EVEN THE PEOPLE
CLAIMING IT’S NOT.
TRUTH IS A DEFENSE NO MATTER
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AT THIS
MOMENT.
THIS MOMENT WILL PASS, REMEMBER
THAT.
WHEN IT DOES, WE WILL LOOK BACK
AT WHAT WE JUST SAW IN HORROR
AND DISBELIEF, BUT IF YOU ARE
HONEST NOW, YOU’LL KEEP YOUR
DIGNITY AND ULTIMATELY, YOU WILL